oh he hit a flamethrower no no i
tattooed it oh tattooed that's gonna be
close to being
really good or in the desert i don't
know i hit it hard
all right stephen curry
this is fourth yeah you want to just
give that to him
that's good we'll give you that one oh
my
goodness that's disrespectful right
there that's a strong cocky move right
right don't let it backfire hey it's
off-season
i'm tired of your colleagues
disrespecting you i had balls made
with shaq's face on it oh yeah knock a
shack ball in the hole
this is ugly okay that's the ugliest
ball in the world right here
so now phil for the win for birdie here
just
go up four no problem
good putt
you got it out that's pretty good all
right partner go take a look take
another kid at that and then we might
have to
call it a hole i thought i had it why
don't you make it and we can win the
hole
we we we're two putt to win the whole my
man oh okay do you want to hit the
comebacker if i get aggressive
no i don't want you to be aggressive i
didn't see that i'm old for two on big
puss today
oh yes good shot
all right peyton all right partner good
job
there it is that's it
mickelson and barkley win capital ones
the match
champions for change the underdogs
have shocked the world great point
outstanding phil mickelson and charles
barkley congratulations
man good work brother two people two
people thought this was going to happen
just you and me and that's it